what advice would you give to Young
Folks on how to have a life that can be
part
of just tackle the demons as early as
possible whether it's through your r or
through meditation or through whatever
it
means Diaries what whatever it is just
uh walk walk towards the things that are
scary because if you don't
they'll just expand they become bigger
if you avoid if you avoid the demons
they become
bigger what do that mean for you today
are you still missing Jeff I'll always
miss
Jeff but I don't feel like a piece of me
is
missing um and same with Leonard
it's that I did give them a piece of
myself and maybe they gave me a piece of
them
that I hold with me and I cherish but it
doesn't feel like I'm less than or
they're less than or anything's less
than
just you learn to appreciate the
impermanence of everything in
life um impermanence of everything
except for Consciousness I guess you
could say is the only thing that is
permanent
so everything else you learn to
appreciate that impermanence because the
limited amount of of time it like in
this particular body is it's enticing
kind of gives you like a time limit
which is cool I like that so you've come
to accept your own yeah like it's cool
that I'm like okay I got this amount of
maybe this amount of time who knows but
could end today but if I was yeah if I
if I died today I'd be really happy with
my life okay it's not like I'm like oh I
missed out on this and that so you
really want to make sure that every day
could be your last day and you're happy
with that I've always lived that way
yeah I felt this way since I was in my
early 20s i' be like yeah I could die
today sure I don't want to die I have no
reason to die but if I did I know that I
you know put my everything all my effort
and all my passion and all my love into
whatever I've already done so if my
time's up and my time's
up what role does Love play in this
whole thing in The Human Condition well
love is everything I mean if you define
love if you're talking about love as in
romantic love or paternal or maternal
love or if you're talking about love as
in you know in the in an Eastern
tradition like Vidant for instance love
is consciousness love is everything
that's the only permanent thing yeah or
if you were to go come from a Zen or
like a Buddhist perspective they would
say nothingness like Emptiness
is versus fullness well those guys are
really obsessed with the whole suffering
thing and letting go of it
yeah